connell cochran the owner of the widely
popular silver shamrock novelties
halloween mask manufacturing company in
1982 may have been born sometime around
the 10th century in celtic ireland while
it's never made exactly clear just how
old cochrane is what is clear is that
while he appears on the surface to be a
successful 60-something entrepreneur who
essentially runs the small town of
sanamira california he is actually a
sinister child murderer cochrane comes
up with a devious plan to sell hundreds
of thousands of rubber halloween masters
children embedded with a chip that will
eventually kill whoever is wearing it
this is where i would say that a plan to
attack citizens with microchips is a
great plan for a sci-fi horror premise
because nobody would be dumb enough to
think that would actually happen but
here we are
he reveals himself to be a studier of
witchcraft intending to sacrifice as
many children as possible during the
festival of samhain a holiday which
eventually became known in our culture
as halloween although in my culture
that's just every day to learn more
about conal cochrane why he wants to
sacrifice hundreds of thousands of
children and if he can ever actually die
stick around to the end of this video
[Music]
welcome to horror history i've never met
anyone named connell in my entire life
the halloween franchise has endured over
the last six decades thanks mostly in
part to the popularity of its main
antagonist maybe you've heard of him but
there is another antagonist that i find
it just as if not more fascinating and
i'm not talking about dr loomis circa
1989. what about your stepmother jamie
his initial roots could date back
thousands of years cochrane expresses
frustration with the fact that most
people today celebrate halloween without
really understanding its origins
you don't really know much about
halloween
you thought no further than the strange
custom of having your children wear
masks and go out begging for candy he
describes a time over 3000 years ago in
what he refers to as his old celtic
lands where the barriers would be down
between what he describes as the real
and the unreal he explains that this was
a time where the dead could look in on
the living referred to as the festival
of salon he explains that in the
festival they would have to make human
and animal sacrifices saying that the
hills ran red with the blood of animals
and children to completely understand
cochran's motivation for wanting to
sacrifice an entire generation of
children we must take it back to the
original pagan festival of silence
[Music]
the festival of samhain took place
around the 10th century and was one of
the four fire festivals
not that kind of fire festival that
deserves its own episode of horror
history sawin was considered to be the
most significant fire festival meant to
usher in the winter season's harvest it
would take place between the fall
equinox and the winter solstice which
would fall on the night of october 31st
through the morning of november 1st
earth fires and family homes were set to
burn out while the harvest was gathered
the samhain festival was indeed believed
to be a connection between the living
and the spirits of those who had passed
where a barrier would come down there
was a fear that this barrier could be
breachable by fairies or other evil
creatures that could get through and
inflict harm it was believed that the
best way to deflect these evil spirits
was by putting an offering outside of
individual homes while the offerings
usually consisted of parts of the
harvest sometimes they would also
include cattle if cochrane was around
for the original samhain festivals then
he would have been very familiar with
the practice of putting out sacrifices
to ward off monsters and fairies however
the belief system that cochran
subscribes to gets much more specific
and instead of offering crops or
livestock involves the sacrifice of
human children it seems maybe cochrane
just really doesn't like kids i do love
a good joke and this is the best ever a
joke on the children yes by killing them
cochran explains that the last big
festival happened three thousand years
ago when he describes it he's speaking
in the first person suggesting that he
was either there or he's just speaking
on behalf of his people it was the start
of the year in our old celtic lands and
we'd be waiting
in our houses of wattles and clay so if
that was the last big festival and he
was there then what was he doing over
the next three thousand years while
cochran's activity from these festivals
up until the 20th century is not
completely clear we do know what he
accomplished within the last 300. at
some point cochran established a company
known as silver shamrock novelties i'm
guessing the company probably started in
his home country of ireland then at some
point moved to munich germany which he
describes to be the birthplace of this
old woman knitting animatronic which was
developed in 1785. silver shamrocks sold
novelties these are usually gift items
that may appeal to someone without
having much if any practical purpose he
showcases some of his best creations and
what he calls the hall of fame many of
the toys that are featured in the
background look like they may have been
made in the early 1900s many of them are
the kind that wind up or requires some
kind of inner mechanics to move and
function cochrane is also said to be
truly famous for his practical jokes or
prank toys and items he's referred to as
the all-time genius of the practical
joke he invented sticky toilet paper
oh you must know the dead dwarf gag the
soft chainsaw all his from early on it's
obvious that cochran's target
demographic is children and he would
shift his focus over the years to cater
to whatever was popular with kids but
his interest in producing toys had more
than one ulterior motive
[Music]
being a producer of wind-up toys early
on allowed him to learn the engineering
skill to make his figures move and seem
lifelike and with hundreds of years of
practice he mastered the art and became
known for making the most realistic
looking masks on the market which is
part of why they're so popular put these
two skills together and it becomes very
easy to see why cochran's plans and
schemes are so threatening cochran's
factory workers as well as most citizens
in the town of satamira seem to be under
his complete control his men seem to
have an almost robotic level of
obedience towards him but what outsiders
don't realize is that this is because
robotic is exactly what they are
cochrane set up an entire town of robots
to do all of his bidding both for his
business his town and for his overall
sacrificial plan because of the fact
that he spent likely hundreds of years
developing the mechanisms for his toys
and figures to move he was able to apply
all of that knowledge towards creating
an entire town of robots
the surprising thing is that the
internal components were quite simple to
produce really
the outer features took much longer to
perfect but then of course in the end
it's just another form of mask making
the business arrived at the small
farming town of santa maria california
in 1945 after world war ii it's no
mistake that cochran chose to build his
factory far away from civilization where
he could still launch a successful
business but without a large population
being able to see exactly what he was
doing by then cochran was already
described as being wealthy which means
that he likely already had a successful
business by this point the entire city
is placed under constant surveillance
and is locked down with a six o'clock
curfew allowing cochrane to do whatever
he wants under the cover of nightfall
without having to worry about the prying
eyes of the townspeople seeing what he's
up to but how is conal cochrane able to
keep himself alive for so long as he
explains the history of the festival of
samhain he confirms that he harnesses
what most outsiders would refer to as
witchcraft but he simply sees it as a
form of alchemy that his people use to
control the world this would actually
make sense especially in 1982 in the
early 1980s modern pagans known as
wiccans started a revival of someone
which was a ceremony involving music and
dance called witches balls a very not
good title but at least they didn't call
them cochran balls however in real life
sacrificing children was not part of the
festival that's a pretty specific
cochrane thing maybe he was bullied by
some kids one time or something by 1982
the main focus of silver shamrock was
selling halloween mass for kids but
again the mass were only part of a much
larger plan his real goal was to get the
kids wearing their masks in front of a
television screen where a hypnotic
advertisement would trigger a particle
within the mass and a beam would turn
the kids heads into a series of bugs and
snakes making a tv program the center of
his plan fits in with what cochrane has
basically done all along follow the
interests of the youth the 1980s were
the beginning of a golden age for kids
television program youth pop culture was
driven by things like teenage mutant
ninja turtles and transformers whose
popularity revolved around cartoons
airing at the time cochrane has to
commit the sacrifice in 1982 due to the
alignment of the planets during that
year's festival to pull this off he
needs a magical artifact a monolith from
the famous prehistoric monument
stonehenge this is because each part of
stonehenge is meant to represent one of
the 19 cycles of the moon basically the
planetary alignment is what allows the
magic inside the monument to become
active to give himself time to produce
and distribute mass containing specs
from the monument he steals it nine
months ahead of halloween in january of
1982. the disappearance of the
stonehenge monument ends up being a
mystery to the press from the public's
perspective it just disappears overnight
we don't know exactly how he got such a
massive artifact out of england and into
the western united states other than the
fact that he was aided by an army of
robots and still we had a time getting
it here but we do know that his evening
lockdown of santa mira probably made it
easier to sneak five tons of blue stone
back into his factory as the season of
the witch approached he used his profits
from years and years of successful
entrepreneurship to fund a massive tv
and radio marketing campaign ensuring
that his mass would be the most popular
halloween mask around kids
[Music]
there seems to even be something
hypnotic about the commercial perhaps
brainwashing them into wanting these
masks more than any other it seems that
cochrane is able to test the potency of
the microchips inside of his mass and
their response to the hypnotic
commercial by arranging several tv
monitors using the same layout as the
stones in the stonehenge monument when
viewed from above the spacing of each
television monitor mimics the formation
of stonehenge and the tops of the
television monitors connect with the
stone and start to glow throughout the
course of the days leading up to
halloween in 1982 there is an
advertisement playing constantly for
three silver shamrock mass along with
the big giveaway that's supposedly going
to occur on tv on halloween nights
everything goes according to plan until
cochrane comes across a man named harry
grimbridge harry was a shop owner local
to california who came to the factory to
pick up a new shipment of mass in person
on october 20th 1982 cochrane would
often give his top sellers tours of the
factory perhaps to help incentivize high
sales of course he wouldn't show them
the most important part of the mask
making process what he calls final
processing where the stonehenge particle
microchip is implanted it seems at some
point during his tour mr grimbridge
discovered what really goes on in final
processing and made it his goal to warn
the public about it so cochran sends one
of his androids to hunt him down with
instructions to kill grimbridge and then
self-destruct of course this raises a
lot of eyebrows around the scene of the
accident and eventually on october 29th
mr grimbridge's doctor and his daughter
show up in sanamira looking for answers
about his untimely death
they set themselves up at a local motel
not yet knowing that this was a part of
cochran's area of influence seemingly
everybody in town is enamored with him
as if he were someone like walt disney a
sort of magical wonder others like marge
guptman who is also there to pick up a
shipment are annoyed with him and his
big business tactics cochran's plan for
dealing with the doctor daniel chalice
and the daughter ellie grimbridge is
essentially sweep everything under the
rug and pretend that harry picked up his
order and went on his way this is
complicated however when marge gutman
gets curious about the chip that she
discovers in the back of the silver
shamrock trademark attached to each mask
and prides at it with a hairpin causing
it to misfire blowing a hole through her
face with a laser and causing bugs to
come crawling out he sends his androids
to clean up the mess and cochran himself
is even forced to come out and assess
the situation in the middle of the night
where he meets ellie and chalice for the
first time he assures them that miss
gutman is going to be sent to the
factory where they supposedly have
excellent medical facilities but chalice
being a doctor himself isn't really
buying it i mean why would a mask and
toy factory have its own hospital i mean
that's just asking for a lawsuit this
isn't a great excuse from cochran to be
honest and i think at this point he was
just so close to halloween and achieving
his goal that he figured he could tell
them anything and it would buy him
enough time to finish carrying out his
plans he even tries to act hospitable
the next day when they show up at the
factory by inviting chalice and ellie
along as he gives another tour this time
to buddy kupper and his family a mass
store owner and the number one silver
shamrock salesman in the country before
going on the tour chalice introduces
himself and ellie as mr and mrs smith
which cochran already knows is not true
because he's had an eye on them for a
while and knows exactly who they are and
why they're here he wants to send them
away peacefully though so he makes a big
spectacle by offering to replace mr
grimbridge's lost odor for free hoping
to distract them from the possibility
that his factory had anything to do with
harry's death
about the confusion over your order i
just tell you one thing a replacement
order is being prepared for you
absolutely free the whole thing's on me
he also has a big mural of himself right
behind him so between those two things
in fact that he basically made himself a
mayor of a town of robots the man seemed
to have a pretty fragile ego perhaps he
should have spent less time
congratulating himself and more time
hiding evidence because ellie at one
point spots her father's car in plain
sight and immediately knows that this is
where he ran into trouble before they
can get out of town and sound the alarm
he has some of his rowboys kidnap ellie
at this point for reasons that are still
entirely unclear to me cochrane creates
a robot version of ellie i guess if i'm
gonna try to put a reasoning behind this
he did this as a backup plan to maybe
try to stop chalice if he's somehow able
to escape the town and try to warn the
public about the silver shamrock mass in
any event it's pretty impressive that
he's able to create a perfect robot
replica of her in just one day he sends
his bots after chalice too but he sneaks
away out of their grasp and goes to the
factory to try to save ellie cochran
quickly learns of the intrusion and goes
to find one of his androids has been
dismantled by chalice and his knitting
woman animatronic decapitated this time
when he sees his intruder he doesn't
bother with entertaining the false name
that he gave last time ah mr cellis
where is ellie
mrs smith he takes chalice prisoner
overnight so the next day is halloween
and cochran takes a moment to appreciate
and breathe in that fresh autumn hair he
knows that this is his big day and he's
about to gain an immeasurable amount of
power he takes chalice down to the final
processing area now i know evil
monologues where the bad guy explains
his entire plan before it's too late for
the hero to do anything about it or a
common movie trope because the audience
needs to understand what's going on and
that's an easy way to do it so that's
probably why he essentially reveals
everything to dr chalice but on the
other hand i'm here to analyze his
character so let's look at why he might
have done this i imagine that the man
lived a very lonely life he secludes
himself up to a small town in northern
california where he's surrounded
entirely by robots with very little
personality he's been alive for probably
thousands of years all of his original
friends and family have most likely
passed at this point and if any of them
have survived like he has i imagine that
they're all the way back in ireland
cochran seems to be a classic case of
the lonely at the top ceo this probably
explains why he puts on the act of being
overly hospitable when people come to
pick up the orders and why he enjoys
giving tours of the factory the man is
starved for human interaction so he
decides to get the most out of chalice
before killing him by explaining his
entire plan that probably also explains
why he remains so friendly with the man
who's trying to expose him and take him
down he even shows chalice a
demonstration of the power bestowed
inside of each silver shamrock halloween
mask when the planets are aligned
properly the cup for family who he had
given a tour of the day before is placed
inside of a test room and a version of
the silver shamrock advert is played
causing the young cover boy to pass out
as his insides are turned into a horde
of crawling insects and aggressive
servants he leaves chalice tied up in
another test room that evening and
places a mask over his face planning to
let the silver shamrock commercial do
the rest of the work and
happy halloween
cochrane goes back to his command center
at final processing where he makes a few
last-minute phone calls and tells
someone that the halloween giveaway is
just gonna be a fun thank you for his
customers when he's informed of a camera
malfunction in chalice's room he sends
his drones in where they discover that
their prisoner has escaped but he shows
no concern because he's already got a
plan b he simply watches as chalice goes
to save what he thinks is ellie but is
actually robo ellie who is programmed to
kill him if he manages to escape however
dr chalice doesn't act as cochran
expected him to instead of leaving the
factory he sneaks back into the final
processing room and starts playing the
commercial internally he sees chalice
scurrying away and sends his androids
after him as he climbs up above the
ceiling raptors where he dumps an entire
box full of mass trademarks down onto
the factory floor while the commercial
is blasting through the television
monitors this activates each of the
buttons and the part of stonehenge
residing in the factory the interference
causes all of the robots in the area to
malfunction and fall to the ground yet
still cochran doesn't seem concerned
thrown off or even frustrated at his
plans being thwarted in fact he seems
quite the opposite he gives chalice a
slow clap as he does so the stone zaps
him and he seemingly turns to stone
himself which looks like either
something out of a nightmare or
something out of a hilarious meme then
he completely disappears he doesn't burn
up or turn into a swarm of bugs like the
victims that we had previously seen
there's still some debate as to what
happened here did cochran use the
witchcraft that he was so familiar with
to teleport himself out of the factory
or was the beam coming directly from the
stonehenge monument itself so powerful
that it essentially zapped him out of
existence personally i read this as the
death of connell cochran but to be
honest we'll probably never find out for
sure since it's been 40 years with no
more halloween spin-off movies and the
great diana harrelly who played conal
cochran in the film is no longer with us
that being said i'd definitely be in
favor of them making a movie called
halloween 3-2 so if you're watching this
universal let's make that happen that
will conclude today's lesson but let me
know what other halloween characters
you'd like to see covered here on horror
history subscribe to cz's world for new
horrors every week ring that death bell
and make sure you select all
notifications and i'll see you in the
next one assuming we both survive
[Music]